Britain has always been a maritime
nation linked to the rest of the world
by the Seas and rivers that feed us and
now Sky News has learned that in future
Goods coming into British waters may
face fewer charges than ever before
an intentional echo of Britain's history
as a trading nation a history that
begins in this place for centuries this
was the epicenter of British trade and
if you were bringing goods into the
country you would have to take them here
custom-house you'd come up this
staircase having more drillship on the
river outside you would go through this
corridor with all of the details of what
you were importing whether it was food
spices plus textiles and you would take
them in here this it's the long room and
here you'd go up to the counter over
there you'd pay your duties to the
officials and only then could you sell
those goods on to the merchants who were
thronging around this room today the
tariffs aren't processed on written
Ledger's and books everything's done
electronically but the same principle is
in place when goods enter this country
they pay a tariff a kind of tax for the
past 45 years those tariffs were decided
by the EU but when the UK leaves
especially without a deal it may
suddenly be able to decide them all over
again so why does that matter for the
rest of us because so much of what you
buy in the shops has to come from
overseas which means it faces tariffs
and that might be good news for
producers here in the UK but it's bad
news potentially for shoppers because
higher towers mean higher prices and
that's why the government is considering
in the event of a no deal brexit cutting
those towers in fact across the board to
give you an idea of what we're talking
about this shows you the UK schedule of
tariffs every single item coming into
this country and Whitehall sources tell
me the plan is to cut 80 to 90 percent
of those tariffs down to zero it would
represent the single biggest
liberalization of trade in British
history some goods will be protected
lamb and beef imports will still have
big tariffs to safeguard farmers but
most foods for instance the cereals used
to make bread and snacks like crisps are
expected to see their tariffs cut to
zero car imports will still face a ten
percent
but the tariffs on car parts will be
slashed it's a difficult balancing act
tariffs always have the potential for
controversy between producer interests
consumer interests even between
different producers between people who
use products to make end products this
has the potential to be really
controversial in most countries and
we've avoided much of that in the UK
this 21st century custom schedule is
still a closely guarded secret in
Whitehall and if there's a deal next
week it may never see the light of day
but it is the first hint of the answer
to the biggest question of all what is
this maritime nation's economic destiny
after it leaves the EU Eddie Conway Sky
News